the presenters of the film editing award  vs. the lady who turned James Barnes  head and diamonds are forever miss Jill  st. John and the Academy Award winner  mr. Rouge but Tom's better known as red  buttons trying to splice them together  know that film editing is not only a  craft but an art precisely but for 44  years of every Oscar show the people  standing here have explained what film  editors do if there's anyone who doesn't  know by now I say good luck to you and  you shouldn't be out after 6:00 the  artist nominated tonight for best  achievement in film editing are Stuart  Gilmour and John W homes for the  Andromeda strength bill Butler for a  Clockwork Orange  Jerry greenberg the French Connection  Ralphie Winters for Koch former Blanche  Ted summer of 42 and the winner is Jerry  greenberg for the French Connection  in the interest of brevity thank you for  the Academy Phil D'Antoni doe freaking  and the New York City subway system